what do you see next in terms of the
Sofia Empire like what is the next year
five years look like for you 2020 was my
year of being like letting everything go
and just like no fear I feel like for a
while I kind of held back on things
because I was afraid of failure
so 2020 is like no fear I'm gonna be
doing acting stuff really soon and that
was big for me to kind of get into
because I just like didn't want to fail
but I'm so glad I didn't because like
great things are happening and I'm
really excited about it are you
auditioning right now are you reading
scripts what can you tell us this is
amazing it's so much but awesome things
is there a dream roll out there for you
oh that's a good question
the rolls I'm reading right now are very
like close to I feel like are kind of
similar to me so they're easy for me to
play and I really really enjoy it so I
think I've been enjoying these roles are
similar to me well these are TV oh
you're just fished it's my job it's my
job um TV TV yeah that's amazing I mean
we did see you on a certain reality show
are we gonna see I mean fans went
seriously insane for you are we gonna
see more of you next season on that show
No
why not well because I want I want to
get into acting yeah yeah do you feel
like because of who your family is it's
easier or harder to kind of get into the
acting world and be taken seriously um
it's always been my thing kind of
growing up like I kind of felt like I
was stuck in everyone's shadow
but I'm very different from both my
sister and my dad so I feel like I've
kind of navigated into my lane and it's
it's been great for me we have seen your
sister act any chance we could see you
guys on a show together do you talk
about that we don't talk about that but
that would be awesome
that was pretty awesome she's hilarious
by the way teracle one of the funniest
people I've ever known I mean we're out
here we're celebrating Marcel we're
celebrating fashion how would you
describe your sense of style lately that
is like the most commonly asked question
I think that has been asked and my
answer is always different honestly my
honest answer is it depends on my mood
yeah I have I'm a billion different
people when I want to be so it honestly
depends on what I'm doing and how I'm
feeling
I mean it's fair that you say that
because you are quite the fashion
influencer if you will I mean your
Instagram is amazing how do you feel
having so many people kind of look up to
you and what you're doing is there a
responsibility there there's it's first
of all it's an awesome feeling um you
know I feel like my instrument like
hearted it's just kind of photos of me
and my fashion and just very light
hearted I never get too deep on my
Instagram so I feel like people get a
good sense of just like fun me and it's
important to me that I keep it very
light-hearted why don't you share more
why don't you get deep on on the gram I
personally feel like everyone's a critic
and no matter what you say people are
going to critique and I am very I I have
a very strong belief in what I whatever
I believe in in certain situations and I
don't really care to hear what people
think about my opinion so that's why I
keep my Instagram very light-hearted
yeah I mean I do feel like you are at
this kind of insane level of Fame right
now how is that to cope with
it's weird cuz I don't feel like that
you don't but you don't feel like that
don't feel like that I think I grew up
with a famous dad so I'm just kind of
used to the noise yeah I mean and your
sister - I mean do they sort of help you
in terms of navigating I mean the media
the paparazzi the Instagram commenters
yeah you know since I was really young
my at both of them have always been like
you can't care what anyone has to say
about you you just have to know who you
are and I've always stuck with that and
I've always been confident with that
[Music]